stavros another boat stole God okay so I
know there's kind of reputation of me
because the kind of fanboy out of Star
Wars [ __ ] I try to keep my [ __ ] together
but at the end of this trailer I was I
was like range I was like ah trailers no
denying that [ __ ] trailer is great and
this trailer leaves a lot open to
speculation that's why we're here let's
talk about what I saw because some
people on Twitter like yep this woman do
the first you hear Snoke like when I
first met you I felt raw power which
then the trailer illustrates that Rae
also has that raw power after a gives
Luke the lightsaber looks like this is a
pretty sweet Jedi outfit I'm gonna trade
it in to where it tarp she's training
and she's apparently so intense with the
force she cracks on the ground and looks
like nope feels like I've seen this kind
of power only one other time it did not
scare me enough then it does now it's
true that kind of does what a Star Wars
trailer does was like all right here's
what Rey's doing here's what kylo ren's
doing here's what the people are doing
and when you look at what they're doing
they're not necessarily doing things in
the same place which does make me think
of Empire Strikes Back where's like
Luke's over here training everyone else
is over here investment the crew gets
divided what we're gonna do here you see
kylo Ren smashed his helmet which I
figured he was gonna do well the promo
stuff you see Kylie run without his
helmet you saw the smashed helmet and
the previous trailer which I think it's
great because I figured he had his
helmet because he was posturing didn't
want anyone to know who he was you know
want anyone to know he was ultimately
this young dude but now cats out of the
bag but they are teasing the [ __ ] out of
us in this when kylo ren's like let the
past die and then he's flying like a
boss this dude is quite a pilot best
pilot in the resistance maybe best pilot
in the galaxy it's up for debate I'd
love to see those two go at it though
but he flies into a resistance ship and
you can tell Leia looks up she can sense
him he can sense her and he's about to
push the button is he gonna kill her we
don't know but you know that [ __ ] is in
there because we know she's not gonna be
in episode 9 so now we're left to wonder
like is that how Leia goes out well it
all depends on when he gets that black
tape over his scar I feel like it's only
gonna be early on because everything
else we've seen he doesn't have that on
in which case that scene is going to
take place earlier on in the movie in
which case Leia is not gonna die because
we've heard she has a very prominent
role in this movie but if he puts
electric tape on his face later on in
the movie it's perfectly possible
there's been an image or an action
figure or something we've seen Finn in
that what looks like an officer's outfit
which made us think does it go back to
the first order did you like sorry guys
being on your side just got my spine
sliced up might as well go back parently
not because it looks like he gets
to a fight with phasma which again love
that too because Finn's role in the
force awakens look like he was just
there for a rope-a-dope he was there for
us to think he was going to be the
forest user that it turned out to be
right the dude really needs his own arc
here fighting phasma the embodiment the
one who ruled over your life your former
leader that's a pretty good way to do
that I love the music - it's a little
bit of a take of the Imperial March so
I'm a kylo steam summer Rae's thing luke
going this is not going to end the way
you think given the information the
trailer gives me it looks like Luke
trains Ray Ray's power freaks Luke out
he's like you know what now go back to
cleaning droids it'll be better for you
it's time for the Jedi to end because
you cracked my floor at which point
she's left without anyone so she tells
of all people kylo Ren I need someone to
show me my place in all this and he
looks at her and holds out his hand and
he doesn't have the weird black electric
tape on his face that he had before in
the trailer which means it's probably at
the end or insufficient or who knows I
know the running chatter is kylo Ren's
turning good what you have are two
characters one was the hero in the last
movie one was the villain ultimately if
it's Ray's turning kylo good it could be
kylos turning Rey back or maybe they're
meeting in the middle somewhere maybe
they're both gonna be like you know what
screw Luke screw Snoke screw these old
dicks let's just go out and do our own
thing guys in the end as far as trailers
go this is great do I need another one
no I don't want any more trailers having
the last trailer and this trailer we
kind of get the vibe it's easy in this
day and age to get your head flooded
with a bunch of stuff but this trailer
did with Star Wars trailers do and that
has put Star Wars at the forefront like
yeah this is happening I'm pumped but I
want to know what you guys think so the
star wars the last Jedi trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it what
do you think they're gonna go what do
you think they're gonna do we didn't see
Luke strike his lightsaber but you know
that shit's gonna happen whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]